翻訳: Kazunori Akashi
校正: Hiroko Kawano
（動画）（歓声）
みんな嬉しそうですね
これは 僕が言い出しっぺで
みんなで作った
日本で初めての全寮制の
インターナショナルスクール「ISAK」の
卒業式の光景です
自然に囲まれた軽井沢の中で
39カ国150人以上の
子どもたちが集まって
デザイン・シンキングや
マインドフルネス・リーダーシップを学んで
次世代のリーダーを目指して
頑張っています
いろんな国の 文化も育ちも違う
子どもたちが集まっているので
いろんなことが起こります
例えば
インドの「アウトオブカースト」
最下層から来た12歳の子どもは —
まあ よく国際会議で
インド人を黙らせるのと
日本人を喋らせるのが
一番難しいって言うんですけども —
（笑）
授業中は本当にずっと発表していて
もう ずっと手を挙げて
元気過ぎて大変だったんですね
ところがランチになると
全然 食べないんですね
それで代表理事の
小林りんちゃんが
「和食は口に合わないの？」って
いうふうに聞いたら
急に泣き始めちゃったんですね
というのは 小さい時から
これだけしか食べたことがないから
胃袋が小さくて
でも孤児院で
絶対 残しちゃダメだっていうふうに
教育を受けているから
必死で食べようと
してるんですけれども
食べられなくて
泣き出してしまったんですね
それを見ていた 隣のお金持ちの
イギリス人の女の子は
実はいろいろ悩んでいて
登校拒否になってたんですけれど
その後 代表理事の
小林りんちゃんのところに来て
自分がいかに恵まれているかっていうのが
初めてわかった —
今後どうやって人生を生きていくか
真剣に考えたいっていうふうに
言ってきたそうです
投資家である僕が
どうして全然 畑違いの
学校を作ろうと思ったかといいますと
いろんな起業家を見ていて
ハングリーで才能のある
起業家は本当にすごいなと
そう考えると —
発展途上国の ハングリーで
才能のある子どもたちっていうのは
世界を変えるリーダーになりうる —
世界の宝だなっていう気持ちが
すごく強くなったからです
そういう子どもたちに
日本で教育の機会を与えて
先進国の子どもたちも
一緒に勉強したら
多様性の中で色んなことを感じ 学ぶ
素晴らしい学校ができるんじゃないかと
思ったからです
学校を作るとなると
子どもたちに幸せになってもらうことが
一番大切です
それで初めて
何が幸せかというのを考えて
３つキーワードがあるなと
思うようになりました
１つ目は絆
これは友達でも彼女でも
家族でも地域貢献でも
何でもいいんだと思います
ダライ・ラマみたいに
宇宙に繋がっている人は
本当に幸せだろうなと
いうふうに思います
自分よりも大きな何かと
繋がっているっていう感覚は
幸せの大前提だと思います
２つ目は成長
80歳になっても
より良い寿司を目指して 自分の
寿司を作っている寿司職人の方ていうのは
人生を通じてとても
幸せなんじゃないかと思います
いくつになっても 少しでもいいから
何らかの成長を感じられるというのは
幸せのとても大きな
要素だと思います
３つ目は 社会の基準に関係なく
自分を表現するということ
今日は このことについて
お話ししたいと思います
投資家として常々
事業を 誰がやるかに尽きるなというのは
ずっと感じていたんですが
ISAKの場合は
小林りんちゃんという
素晴らしいリーダーに出会えて
とても幸運でした
彼女こそ 社会の基準に関係なく
120%自分を表現する人でした
最初 彼女はアジアの
社会起業家を育てるファンドを
作りたいということで
僕のところに相談に来ました
ずっと学校をやる人を
探していた僕は
彼女の人を動かす力に
感銘を受けて
ぜひ一緒に学校を作らないかという
話をしました
アジアで才能がある
ハングリーな子どもたちに
教育の機会を与えてあげたら
そのうちの一部は ひょっとしたら
国に戻って その国の
リーダーになるかもしれない
そうしたら その方がずっと
長い目で見たら
社会にインパクトを与えられるし
りんちゃんが
本当にやりたいことに
近いんじゃないかという
話をして説得しました
最初 彼女はびっくりしていましたが
学校の理念にすごく共感してくれて
代表を引き受けて
くれることになりました
一旦 代表になると
本当に ものすごい勢いで
学校の立ち上げに奔走し始めて
まずベンチャー企業の
経験を生かして
そのままスタッフを雇い
次に不動産事業をやってきた
経験を生かして
土地を買い 校舎を建て
それからUWCや
スタンフォードの経験を生かして
世界中から先生を連れてきて
ユニセフの経験を生かして
サマーキャンプの学生を
連れてきてっていうふうに
彼女がやってきたことを
全部使って
もう本当 ダンプカーのように
次々と実行していきました
で 今や 彼女は自分がやってきたことを
全部使っているので
自分は この学校を作るために生まれてきた
というふうに言っているくらいです
そんな彼女を見ていて
ふと スティーブ・ジョブズの
有名なスタンフォードのスピーチの
「Connecting the dots（点をつなぐ）」の
話を思い出しました
ジョブズが大学の時に
カリグラフィーのクラスで学んで
それが10年後 Macを作る時に
再び蘇ってきて
思いがけず
すごく役に立ったっていう話です
僕は これはずっと
過去やったことが自然と繫がるっていう
教訓だと思っていました
でも りんちゃんを見ていて
120%自分を表現する人というのは
ドットは自然と繫がるのではなくて
自ら 自分でドットを繋げていくんだな
というふうに思うようになりました
ジョブズの場合でも
よく考えてみたら
あんなに字体の数がなくても
Macはヒットしたかもしれないと
思うんですよね
でも大事なのは
ジョブズが 自分が学んだことを
すべて使って 120%自分を表現した
だからこそ 世界中の人が
感動するような
素晴らしいコンピュータができた
同じように りんちゃんも
もし モダン・アートとかやってたら
校舎を建てずに廃校を使って
モダンアートで
クリエイティブな校舎を作るとか
そういうのもあり得たと
思うんですけど
でも大事なのは 彼女が
これまでやってきたことを全部使って
120%自分を表現したからこそ
ISAKも素晴らしい学校に
なろうとしている
これまでやってきたことを
すべてつぎ込んで 自分を120%表現する —
それこそが 「connecting the dots」 の
本当の意味なんじゃないかと
思うようになりました
もう一人 僕がとても尊敬している
自分の友人で
オランダ人のボリス・ディトリッヒさんの
話をさせてください
彼は LGBTの活動家で
ヒューマン・ライツ・ウォッチっていう
国際人権団体の活動で
僕は 彼と一緒にやって
彼の生き方に
本当に感銘を受けました
ボリスは大学生の時までは
自分でも 自分がゲイだっていうのを
認めることができず
女の子と付き合っていたそうです
アメリカ留学中に
たまたま連れて行かれたゲイの集会で
そのゲイのリーダーに
突然 指を指されて
「お前はゲイだ 俺にはわかる」って
いうふうに言われたそうです
びっくりしてボリスは
その場を立ち去ったんですが
やっぱり自分はゲイだと思って
親に告白することを決めます
そしたら何と ちょうどその時に
親から手紙をもらうんですね
その手紙には
「今日 ディトリッヒ家では
本当に悲しいことがあった
それは お前のお姉さんが
レズビアンであることを告白した
これで もうお姉さんからは
子孫は生まれない
でもいいニュースもある
それは ボリスという
素晴らしい息子がいて
彼が必ずディトリッヒ家を
繁栄させてくれるだろう」と
書いてあったらしいんですね
その手紙を受け取って
ボリスは親が悲しむのを考えて
告白するのをやめて
また勉学に励んで
オランダに帰って
国際弁護士になって
社会の模範のような
成功者の人生を歩んでいました
ちょうどその頃
テレビのニュースを見ていると
ゲイのリーダーが射殺されたという
ニュースを見て
彼は衝撃を受けるんですね
殺されたのはハーヴェイ・ミルク
有名なLGBTの活動家で
サンフランシスコの市会議員だった人です
そのミルクこそが
ボリスを指差して
「お前はゲイだ」って言った
その彼だったんですね
彼はそれを見て
突然 自分はミルクが
果たせなかったことをやるために
生まれてきたというふうに
思ったらしくて
それで 今度は迷わず
親にカミングアウトします
親が 案の定
すごく嘆くのを見て
ボリスは 親がこれだけ言う「弱み」を
自分の強みに変えてみせるというふうに
誓ったそうです
それから彼は
社会派の弁護士に変わって
ゲイとして初めて
最高裁の判事になり
同性婚を成立させるために
ゲイとして初めての国会議員になり
ついに連立野党の
党首になります
そこで 同性婚の法律を
ついに議会で通して
オランダは世界で初めて
同性婚を認める国になります
その後 周囲で 首相になるんじゃないか
という期待もあったのに
ボリスは あっさり議員を辞めて
今度は国際人権団体に入って
世界中のLGBTの人たちの
人権を守るために
本当に世界中を奔走して —
ロシアとかアフリカとか行ったら
身の危険を冒しながら
奔走して その活動をしています
その活動が認められて
ついに ゲイとして初めて
オランダの女王から
ナイトの称号を得ました
ボリスは 社会の基準に関係なく
自分を120%表現している
素晴らしい例だと思うんですね
LGBTの人は
もう本当に大変で
社会の基準に
合わせようがありません
だからこそ
一旦カミングアウトすると
社会の基準に関係なく
自分を表現できる —
ある意味 弱みを強みに変えている
僕は これからのリーダーというのは
マイノリティから出てくると
思うんですね
マイノリティの人たちは
自分を表現するハードルが物凄く高い分
一旦それを乗り越えると
今度は無茶苦茶に 自分を表現できる
傷ついた痛みを
本当に知っているからこそ
本当に強くて 優しい
現代社会は 行き過ぎた資本主義の
揺り戻しが起こっていると思うんですね
力による支配とか
あまりにも大きな貧富の差に
多くの人は
疲れ切っていると思います
だからこそ 多様性の中で
痛みが分かるリーダーというのは
これから活躍すると思います
ここで僕が強調したいのは
120%自分を表現する
リーダーっていうのは
いわゆるリーダー
大会社の経営者とか 政治家とか
そういう いわゆるリーダーでは
ないっていうことです
これからのリーダーっていうのは
自分自身のリーダーになって
ありのままの自分を
表現する人だと思います
ついつい知らず知らずのうちに
社会の基準に影響されて
自分が いわゆるリーダーになりたいと
思いがちだと 思うんですけれども
男でも女でも
専業主婦・主夫に
なりたいんであれば
それが一番幸せだし
社会にとっては それが一番
素晴らしいことだと思います
一人ひとりが
社会の基準に関係なく
自分のやりたいことを見つけ
120%自分を表現する
宇宙船地球号の乗組員として
宇宙がよりよくなる方向に
一人でも多くの人が ありのままの
自分を表現できるようになれば
世の中はもっと良くなると思います
こうやって
人の話ばかりしてきましたが
僕自身はどうかというと
なかなか自分でやることを見つけられず
ずっと苦労しています
ボリスやジョブズみたいに
１つのことをやり続ける人に
ずっと憧れて
自分にとって それは何かなというのを
ずっと探してきたんですけれども
好奇心が多すぎて なかなか
１つのことが続けられず
ずっと悩んできました
でも ISAKをやる時に
このエドワード鈴木さんという
建築家に出会って
建築家というのは
住む人のために
いい家を いくつも作る
仕事だな と
そうであるならば 僕も建築家に
なりたいなと思うようになりました
本当はね —
もう 無茶苦茶カッコいいですよね
本当は
ルックスもこうなれたら
一番いいんですけどね
（笑）
僕にとっての
いい作品というのは
120%自分を表現する人が
増えるような場所を
作るということです
主役は活躍する人
で そういう場所 いい作品を
いくつも作るっていうのが
自分にとっての 自分の120%の
表現かなと思うようになりました
これまで作った作品としては
「お金のデザイン」 であったり
「Campus for H」であったり
「ISAK」であったり
「ライフネット生命」であったり
「スタジオ・ヨギー」だったりするんですが
ここで活躍する人とか
ここに来てくれている
人たちのことを考えると
幸せな気分になります
ボリスは自分のメールの最後に
いつも このメッセージをつけています
「（英語）未来は我々の前でなく
我々の中にある」
皆さんの中には 僕と同じように
まだ自分がやりたいことを
見つけられていない方も
いらっしゃるかと思います
でもボリスが言うみたいに
それは皆さんの心の中
自分自身の中にあるんだと思います
自分にとって より大切なものを
少しずつ選んでいくことによって
いつの間にか 段々と
見つかるものじゃないかな
というふうに思っています
最後に 僕が自分自身にいつも言っている
メッセージを贈らせてください
「（英語）一度の人生（One life）
自己実現の旅を 楽しもう」
「One life」 には２つ意味があります
１つは １回しかない人生
もう１つは自分も 周りの人も
動物も 植物も
地球も 宇宙も１つ
そういうふうに考えると
自然と すべてのものに対する
愛とリスペクトが感じられますよね
「Enjoy 」っていうのは
ただ楽しいっていう意味ではなくて
苦しみもすべて含んでです
僕も いい作品を作ろうと思うと
ジタバタ ジタバタしていて
時々眠れなかったりもします
でもそうやって
ジタバタ ジタバタしている —
その過程こそが
一番充実していて
成長も感じられる
ひょっとしたら一番
幸せな時間なのかもと
思うようになりました
「（英語）一度の人生
自己実現の旅を 楽しもう」
一度しかない人生
自分も周りも１つ
よりよい宇宙に向けて
自分を思いっきり
120%表現する旅を楽しんで
幸せを目指しましょう
ありがとうございました
（拍手）